[Music]
hello there
fortnight season 7 is evolving with only
a few days until ariana arrives the
alien invaders
and io are taking no prisoners with
drastic changes to both the map
and the impending war between them this
is now week 9 of the season
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap code adamaru in the store to help
my random nonsense and let's break down
what's new to the story
in this update
like usual the first thing you'll notice
is an update to the lobby screen
and it's just a taste of things to come
because it's true
slurpee has been changed just a little
you probably won't notice
okay the mother ship has ripped it
completely out the ground everything is
currently floating in the air
the slurp liquid is falling upwards into
the sky as gravity works differently
here now
io have already arrived they set up
outposts and are watching from outside
the zone with launch pads ready to jump
in
io are always watching and so are these
guys
hell yeah the henchmen henchmen are back
yet again
and are now leading their own studies
last week bill
or is it ted somehow figured out sloan's
scientific equations and has taken that
white board all the way over to the new
look slurpee
he's attempting to pass on his knowledge
to ted or is that bill
but this dude ain't too bright bill i
mean ted
is the smart one at some point we need
to figure out which one is which
oh and it looks like we'll be helping
the bromance in a challenge this week
one of deadpool's cameras has an asset
spot in replay mode just here
so we are coming back and in the sky
look this diving hoop challenges again
oh great
okay so let's move on to the biggest
news of the day no no not that thing
this the hashtag tinychair is now
minuscule just look at it it's so teeny
tiny
thank you for this gift we all
challenged you to make this even smaller
and you proved it was possible thank you
very much for that
you have made an unbelievably small
chair firm handshakes all round
if this is the last update to this
ant-man sized chair i'm a happy dude
but we're gonna challenge you again all
the same come on epic make it smaller
i'll take the tiny chair on a tour of
the island it deserves it
this could be foreshadowing a shrinking
ray gun
i need that in my life okay so the real
wow factor of the day is the grabatron
it finally arrived this week we saw it
in the trailer yonks ago
and now it's here and look you can catch
a rocket
mid-air i won't dwell here there'll be a
million creators covering this weapon
today so instead
please send me dumb stuff you can do
with the grabatron
i feel that's a good title for a video
dumb stuff you can do
with the grabatron
[Music]
during this week one of the strangest
updates was added i'm sure you've seen
the bushranger walking around near risky
reals
well a few days ago he stopped
completely and was replaced with this
a gravesite complete with flowers and
this ominous music
if you've been keeping up to date with
the ranger you'll know he has a long
history in fortnite
back in season two of this chapter we
could see bushranger hiding in the
shadows
watching everything and reporting back
to an unknown individual
he's such a master of disguise you can't
tell when he's blending in look he's
here
bushranger has been here on the island
for so many seasons since his
introduction
but last week he received his own
challenges which were to collect records
and
parenting books and this one was the
most important
looking after an alien egg of some sort
those who are og players will recognize
this as an old dragon egg from chapter
one
and those hybrid skins that hatched from
that and then suddenly
bushranger's story went cold he's now in
a ditch in an unmarked grave
can we also make a note that somebody
has buried his body
the shovel sits nearby and confirms
either a passerby took the time to bury
him
or more realistically this is part of a
bigger plan and the bushranger needed
help
and lo and behold that's not the end of
the story because today in the update
things make a little more sense kinda
check back and you'll see the resting
place
of the ranger is now the birthplace of
the ranger
his saddling is now regrowing it's
definitely him it's the exact same style
and it looks like the resurrection of
bushranger is imminent
unless he was taking cuttings of himself
to make himself a partner
like adam and eve i may be going too
deep into this we need to think about it
what's the law here
what the hell is going on epic
a small little update now in a very
peculiar place
the small farm on the hill has been an
important spot for the season with many
alien related elements coming here
but one thing which i still do not
understand are the structures around it
we first noticed that these look like
player made builds like we used to make
in save
the world and right now this spot has
evolved again
it's like a farming version of hot watch
[Music]
maybe not i get a feeling that this is
evolving into a new location for next
season
and the workmanship here will continue
to improve and hopefully
look a little bit more professional next
time it's been suggested that the aliens
who
now can be pretty much anyone on the
island are mimicking loopers
and slowly learning how to build they
aren't cranking 90s just yet but it's a
10 out of 10 for effort for me
like usual let's keep an eye on it next
on to this week's challenges and
something important to note from dr
sloan
she says the dna of the island is being
corrupted they're preparing to terraform
everything as long as totally right
since the first egg was laid the mother
ship has repeatedly attempted to create
a world sustainable to the aliens
eventually reshaping holly adding their
homeworld gravity fields
we already know that coral castle and
the secret bunker under the farming area
are on the list of places to be changed
to suit those alien invaders but we have
more to add to this now
check out this audio from sloan to give
us more context
i have weapons in development that may
be capable of bringing down the
mothership all you need to do is
convince the aliens to bring them on
board
voluntarily the message starts off as a
way to use i o tech on the mothership
but soon becomes clear sloane
is now preparing to crash the mothership
into the island
one minor detail if we take down the
mother ship the crash landing is not
going to be pretty
a few billion tons of flaming debris
crashing into the island is bound to
cause some problems
that will lead to many map changes if
you've been keeping up with sloane it's
unclear whose side she's actually on
she's most definitely loyal to io at
least for now but we also know she's in
cahoots with lex luthor from the dc
world and has opened a rift to
metropolis
and guess who arrived this week superman
whatever game sloane is playing it's
going to be revealed very soon we should
also note that io actively wiped the
memories of characters who know too much
like bunker jonesy the man who set most
of this in motion
by predicting the future is now a shell
of his former self
wiped from existence i don't think it'll
stay like that because bunker johnsy
knows so much he likely had a backup
plan just in case this happened
oh and to add to this have you seen the
meowzal's morsels ads on the island
this looks like a challenge that will be
linked to the law this could be an ad
for add's sake but we know that the
aliens are addicted to cat food so this
is either a ploy by the aliens or in my
humble opinion
this is one of sloane's and io's plans
to capture those infiltrators of the
imagined order
all i know is i kind of want some tuna
fish right now one last thing
leakers have uncovered references to the
return of kevin the cube
we all believed it for a while now but
now there's more evidence should we need
it
sounds of the cube have recently been
added kevin will return and by the looks
of it so will the storm king
he's coming to ariana's concert on
friday maybe this was what raz was
trying to do last season
he may be an evil brute but he does love
some generic pop music
like everyone else the concert could be
a one-and-done kind of thing or it could
give us an insight into other dimensions
in the story
and maybe we'll find out where the
cuddle team leader went
before returning all super badass
charged
right i'm adam you're awesome these guys
are leggings thank you for sticking with
me and using code adamaru on my content
which has been crap this season but i
will improve you have my word
i'm going to break the grabatron now
i'll see you in game tata
[Music]